All right, remember, you can use the coupon
code fresh start.
All one word, all lowercase for the membership
of your choice, join Pakman Dotcom.
We are mostly funded by individual memberships
that join Pakman Dotcom.
And in a little bit later, a little bit later
today, I am going to have a very important
story for you about why it is that we are
mostly funded by individual memberships.
It is time for our first post-election hatriot
mail.
Quick reminder, what is hatriot mail?
Take a listen to this.
Take your mask and shove it.
Now, let me tell you about my fake medical
condition, hatriot mail written by patriots
who hate David Pakman because of America and
because freedom.
OK, this week's Hatriot Mail needs no introduction
other than to say the Patriots are really,
really mad about the election results.
Take a listen to this.
Well, whatever you are, if bidding does win,
God help us.
And you, for one thing, your cheap gas will
go away next if bedin has enough balls to
stand for the next attack on my country.
Next, I hope you like immigrants living in
your backyard also because they will be Mr.
Fake News.
I love my country.
Not like you bunch pantywaist wet behind the
ears mures spreaders.
And when war starts, I'm sure your name will
be brought up to protect your country.
Oh, I forgot.
You're in the wrong country.
I hope you like rice.
Well, I said my piece, which I am at peace
so have a nice life.
Go ex military.
This is just this, this is crazy.
And you know it's again it's easy to just
make fun of people for the bad spelling and
the bad grammar and the incoherence and the
conspiracy theories and the lack of understanding
of politics and the lack of understanding
of math and the lack of understanding of science
and the lack of understanding of psychology
and economics and find it OK, you get the
picture.
But I still maintain that even when somebody
talks to me about being a Muar spreader, which
I think they mean manure spreader, we still
saw nearly 72 million people vote for Donald
Trump.
And if we really want to make progressive
change happen in this country, we either need
to disabuse some of these folks of their bad
ideas or in some way engage with them.
And I am focused on pragmatic.
So you call that restrained when someone is
going completely crazy attacking me.
But I'm focused on the future and that's what
we need to do.
Now, one thing you can do to fight patriotism
is use the coupon code hatriot 40.
When you get a membership at join Pakman Dotcom,
the coupon code Hatriot 40 saves you 40 percent.
And when Hatred's catch wind that the coupon
code has been used, they cry because they
know they realize they're hatriot.
Mail is going nowhere.
That's hkt t Iot for zero on your choice of
membership at Join Pakman Dotcom.